Tesla is temporarily halting its
troubled model 3 sedan production line
the decision comes just a week after CEO
Elon Musk told CBS News that he felt
confident Tesla could emerge from what
he called the cars production hell Tesla
says the shutdown starts today and will
last until Saturday
the automaker hopes assembly line
improvements will increase output it
previously halted production of the
company's first mass-market car for four
days in February and just last week you
may remember that Elon must show us an
area the factory where the assembly line
recently underwent major changes where
we all right now it used to be a huge
conveyor system I guess really
complicated automated conveyor system
like literally where we're standing I
was like it wasn't working
it was like excessive automation that
wasn't working when Elon must spoke with
us last week he did not mention what
Tesla now calls a planned downtime in
the past they have said that you know we
will have planned down times and this
may be one of those but I don't think
that it was a planned downtime at this
particular time because he was so
upfront with us and very candid with us
I can't believe that he would have
withheld that knowing that they were
going to do that this following week
right why not say yeah yeah they moved
up the plan I think something happened I
don't know they didn't see it coming no
no I don't think so